[Music]
the movie starts with several news
channels reporting about a deadly virus
named the saharan flu the flu which has
a 100
fatality rate has decimated the earth
and it is believed that almost 3 billion
people have passed away now with the
human population dwindling at a rapid
rate the united states government has
devised a plan to save the race they
have decided to build 500 000 bunkers
and a lottery will be conducted to
select the people who will be staying in
them each bunker will have only one
inhabitant and they will have to live
there until the flu subsides once
everything is back to normal the people
will be gathered again for a
repopulation program we are then shown
the interior of the fallout bunker which
has enough supplies stored in it to last
an astonishing 70 years the bathroom has
access to a 24-hour water supply which
is recycled and used again for
electricity the inhabitants of the
bunker are made to do regular exercise
when it comes to food they are simply
fed with a protein shake called saplival
which emerges from a tab the bunker also
has accurate weather representations
when it's morning a sunny environment
will be shown and when it's night the
room becomes completely dark this helps
the inhabitants control their sleep
patterns cut to several years later we
are shown a group of seven people
chatting through a video conference
although all of them are living in their
separate bunkers they do everything with
the consent of one another the seven
people are named after their respective
cities and boston a strict but
soft-hearted guy is their leader in one
of these conferences an aggressive man
from the group named orlando berates all
of his friends he also mentions that the
outside world will never revert back to
normal hence they're trapped here their
entire life boston and the others try to
calm him down but orlando does not
listen instead he reveals his gruesome
past where he killed 15 people and got a
life sentence one of the group members
atlanta who is an extremely religious
woman gets angry and confronts orlando
about the murders the deranged killer
simply replies that it gave him pleasure
hearing this the group gets disgusted as
they wish to get rid of orlando once and
for all luckily there is an i.t expert
in the group who goes by the name denver
he mentions that he has learnt how to
hack basic things and can possibly turn
off orlando's transmission however there
is a catch if he turns off the
transmission once it will be impossible
to get it back again this means that if
orlando's video calling ability is
turned off he may have to live the rest
of his life alone without anyone to talk
to and you can be sure that's going to
make him want to kill more people later
the decision is a very tough one so the
group decides to take it to a vote three
people boston atlanta and a man named
chicago vote for orlando's transmission
to be cut off however a woman named
phoenix and another man houston claimed
that the punishment is simply too severe
and hence vote against it this leaves
the decision up to the hacker denver's
vote but before he can speak orlando
himself orders the group to cut off the
transmission claiming that he is sick of
seeing their boring faces obliging to
his request denver hacks the system and
makes orlando disappear forever that
night a sleepless phoenix wakes up and
talks to denver they discuss the earlier
incident and phoenix mentions that what
they did was wrong however denver
consoles her by saying that it was the
best thing to do here it is revealed
that the two are in a relationship
following this the movie fast forwards
to eight months in the future despite
losing one member the group is adjusted
well to the situation however due to an
anomaly in the system houston's weather
lights start changing abruptly because
of this he hasn't been able to sleep for
some days after a while the group starts
their usual meeting and everyone reports
their findings it turns out that all the
members are assigned with a particular
task like atlanta has to keep track of
her group's health while denver is
responsible for notifying everyone about
the outside world's status this is
possible due to the additional computers
in the bunker which shows various
statistics like the amount of people
remaining in the world the heartbeats of
all the group members and so on while
everyone is busy with their tasks
chicago who is the least productive
member of the group gets bored he tells
everyone that everything is futile as
they are never going to see the outside
world again boston tries to scold him
but chicago presses a button on the
computer forcing the bunker's manual to
pop up on everyone's screen since the
video cannot be skipped everyone is
forced to watch it this would be a great
time for some rick astley in the video
the bunker's creator nadine starts
explaining the various amenities inside
the bunker and reveals that it is 30
feet below the surface after this she
mentions that all 500 000 people are
divided into groups and one such group
consists of seven people their only job
is to help each other survive until the
virus is eradicated from the earth the
video ends as nadine narrates that there
is still hope left on this earth for
humanity some days later as the group is
discussing in one of their regular
conferences their data computers
suddenly shut down though boston thinks
it's just a temporary defect the others
fear that their bunker is starting to
disintegrate the strange thing is that
the computers are down in all six of
their bunkers despite them being
thousands of miles away from each other
later phoenix privately calls her
boyfriend denver and tells him that the
system might have been compromised
because of a loophole the loophole
started when they hacked into the system
and shut down orlando's video
transmission phoenix then pleads with
denver to hack into the system again and
bring back orlando as it might be the
only way to restore their data computers
back however denver mentions that
bringing back the transmission is not
possible so it's not worth trying
hearing this phoenix becomes angry and
starts narrating her life story she
reveals that her father died at a young
age and she was brought up by her mother
but while growing up she started doing
drugs and even ran away from home
several times one day when phoenix
didn't find her stash in her room she
suspected that her mother took it hence
in a fit of rage she grabbed a pair of
scissors and stabbed her mother to death
she was then incarcerated in a maximum
security prison until the virus broke
out and she won the lottery to the
bunker after hearing the story denver
becomes emotional and promises to get
orlando transmission back one night he
finally succeeds and calls phoenix to
share the good news surprisingly when
they watch orlando's feed he is nowhere
to be found in the next scene the couple
shows the feed to the rest of the group
and as expected boston is not happy that
they took the decision without informing
anyone he is especially angry at denver
for hacking the system once again
however the couple simply reply that
they don't care about voting anymore at
night phoenix once again calls denver
and asks him if he can retrieve some of
orlando's personal videos that he had
recorded she mentions that the videos
might reveal a clue as to where he went
denver obliges and immediately gets to
work he puts those supreme hacking
skills to the test and eventually
manages to download several of orlando's
personal videos then the couple starts
watching the videos one by one most of
them are just orlando working out
without his shirt on phew god damn but
in the last clip the video is suddenly
cut and only orlando's screams can be
heard when the video comes back on he
has already vanished it appears as if
someone or something took him away and
not even all that working out could save
him the next morning the entire group
discusses the strange video and
everyone's opinions are divided boston
believes that they are safe in the
bunker and that they are simply
overthinking but phoenix asserts that
they have to find a way to escape before
it's too late on the other hand houston
has started to go crazy because of his
damaged weather lights he has not slept
in over a week and as a result he too
supports phoenix's plan of escaping
however boston orders everyone to stand
down until they have conclusive proof
unfortunately things take a turn for the
worse that night as a now deranged
houston starts banging his head on the
wall everyone pleads with him to stop
but at this point he has lost his sanity
just then houston's video transmission
gets interrupted and audio of someone
barging inside his bunker is heard when
the video is back on houston is already
gone just like orlando this shocks the
group and now they finally believe that
something is up the following morning
phoenix takes charge of the group and
instructs everyone to find something in
their bunker from which they can escape
apart from the lazy chicago everyone
agrees and they start inspecting their
places the religious woman atlanta is
the first one to find a lead she breaks
open a pipe through which the supple of
all protein is regulated in her bunker
as the entire group watches closely
atlanta peeks through the pipe and
notices that there is a vacuum space on
the other side this confuses everyone as
the bunker is supposed to be 30 feet
buried beneath the surface but before
they can ask anything atlanta's
transmission is cut and someone
forcefully takes her away witnessing
this the remaining group is devastated
as they realize that anyone can be
apprehended at any time in particular
chicago has lost hope for life he slowly
proceeds near the main door and commits
the unthinkable leaving everyone
devastated now only three people are
remaining in the group although boston
and phoenix have accepted their fate
denver is not ready to give up so easily
he starts hacking into the system with
all his expertise and finally achieves a
breakthrough he summons his distraught
friends via a conference call and
reveals that he has managed to hack into
other survivors bunkers phoenix and
boston don't believe him but when denver
shows them the live transmission of some
other survivors they are taken aback
denver then reveals a strange thing
although he hacked into the entire
system he was only able to find 1 000
bunkers instead of the mentioned 500 000
hearing this phoenix realizes that
something is wrong she then proposes to
denver and boston that they attempt to
escape one last time boston asserts that
there is virtually no way of escaping
the bunker but fenix responds that there
might be one she mentions that if they
cut the wires inside the bunker the dorm
might open the boys think the plan is
risky but phoenix is now willing to put
her life on the line hence seeing her
determination the boys agree to the plan
but before they can begin denver
promises to phoenix that he will travel
across the country on foot if that is
the only way to get to her following
this all three of them begin cutting the
wires as soon as they succeed an alarm
starts ringing and the door finally
opens the first one to venture out is
phoenix surprisingly the door leads to a
normal looking apartment with a large
hallway in it phoenix had always
imagined that she was inside a bunker
but the truth was far from it and before
she can decipher anything denver comes
out of the next door implying that they
were living in the same building for the
past six years as the two embrace one
another in joy and confusion boston also
emerges from another door in the next
scene the three begin investigating the
strange apartment until they reach the
terrace after six long years they have
finally experienced the sunlight
meanwhile phoenix climbs the staircase
to get a better overview of the city
surprisingly everything seems to be
running as usual people are walking on
the streets and the traffic is crowded a
while later phoenix approaches her
friends to share the news but they
appear to be hiding from someone it
turns out the two people who look like
policemen are searching for the trio as
there is no way to escape from the
terrace boston decides to create a
diversion so that his friends can flee
the plan works and the couple climb
downstairs until they reach an office
suddenly the creator of the bunker
nadine arrives with a gun and threatens
denver to stand back she also warns
phoenix to stay away from him claiming
that he is a dangerous person confused
phoenix inquires about what's happening
and nadine finally reveals everything it
turns out that the bonkers are
specialized prisons and all the people
inside of them are prisoners criminals
like phoenix never got out of prison
they were simply transferred to the
bunkers as nadine wanted to give them
hope and a new purpose in life moreover
the saharan flu never existed and the
news reports on tv were simply
fabricated for the prisoners denver's
speculation also comes true when nadine
mentions that only 1 000 prisoners are
jailed in the bunkers then phoenix asks
why the prisoners are being forced out
of their bunkers indicated by the
several recent disappearances nadine
explains that when orlando was kicked
out of the group his video was somehow
leaked to the public and it caused a
public outrage they believed that such
prisoners were given too much freedom
and luxury in the bunker and as a result
the government is ordered to shut down
the project hence they're pulling
everyone out to make some changes in the
bunkers and putting them back in until
they can find a space in the prison
system for them for the time being their
bunkers will be modified in such a way
that the prisoners will have less
freedom and their lives will become more
uncomfortable expectedly the revelation
shocks the couple but phoenix is still
curious about one thing she asks nadine
why denver was incarcerated and the
latter reveals that he stalked 15 women
online and murdered them brutally
hearing this phoenix is devastated as
she realizes that denver was just
pretending to love her all this time but
denver didn't think he was ever getting
out so that twist is dumb soon the
police officers from before arrive in
the room and knock the two out in the
last scene phoenix and denver are taken
to the same hallway where they come
across the entire group except for
chicago orlando is also there but when
he tries to escape he is shot and killed
the movie ends as the remaining five
survivors are sent back to their
respective bunkers which have now been
transformed into a grim terrorizing room
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching